53 degrees outside. 7 p.m. KMUD Garberville, KMUD Eureka, KLAI Laytonville, where the views
and opinions expressed throughout the broadcast day are those of the speaker and not necessarily
the station, staff, underwriters, or volunteers. Sometimes it's not even the speaker's point of
view. They're possibly trolling you, but more likely they're just trying to express somebody
else's point of view so that you can more completely understand the issues at hand.
So don't get mad. Just give your information out too.
[Music]
And I believe I have the herb doctor here. Good evening. And we have Dr. Peat. I'm sorry.
That took so long. Take it away. No problem. No problem. Welcome to this month's Ask Your
Herb Doctor, the see here November 19th edition 2021. My name is Andrew Murray. My name is Sarah
Johannesen Murray. Welcome to our show, Ask Your Herb Doctor. For those of you who just joined us
or have never heard the show before, it runs every third Friday of the month from 7 to 8 pm. We have
a call in, a live call in from 7 30 until the close of the show at 8 o'clock. People are invited
to call in with any questions related to the topic that we're discussing. As has become very
customary now, Dr. Peat is our guest and joining us to share his knowledge. Last month in October,
we opened up a discussion which we couldn't finish in a month and it was concerning metabolic
defects in cancer and also the approach to cancer, the strategies for alternative approaches to
cancer. Dr. Peat has for 35, 40 years been researching and working in alternative medicine
approaches to physiology and has a website with a wealth of information that we'll be giving help
towards the end of the show. Let me just see if Dr. Peat is with us and go from there. Dr. Peat,
are you with us? Yes, I can just barely hear you. Okay, I wonder if you have a volume. Do you have a
volume setting on your phone? It's a tinny quality. It isn't the volume, it's a blurry tinny quality.
Yeah, you guys sound like you're on a speaker phone or something maybe. You're not the best
connection. I think it's okay if callers don't think so, they'll pipe up though. Let me just
ask both of you if this is any clearer now. Did either of you hear that better? I heard a click
and I think it got better but I was also switching from one thing to another here but I think that
is a little better. Yeah, Dr. Peat, do you hear that any better? I can hear you but not the end of
an error. Oh dear. I think that aspect, that's an aspect of our board I think but he doesn't need to
hear me. You guys are the important ones. Yeah, okay. At this point I'm not too sure Sarah can hear us,
that's the only thing. Well, I think we probably just better carry on this way then and just
sometime during Dr. Peat's explanation of some of the questioning we'll be going through to tonight
when perhaps I can get Sarah on and she can be part of that otherwise. Okay, so Dr. Peat, thanks
so much for giving your time again this month. Would you just let people know more about you
from an academic research perspective and then we can carry on the show? Okay, in the 60s I was
studying various subjects in humanities and I decided to go into biology to study the brain
mainly but when I got to graduate school in 1968 my interest went to aging and its influence on the
metabolism of largely the reproductive process, how reproduction influences the general process
of aging and since then I've been following up the same general topics, aging, stress,
sickness and especially how the hormones, reproductive hormones can accelerate or
retard the process of aging. Okay, so in terms of a hormonal physiology for aging that's been
your specialism and I know you've worked in many other relative branches of that surrounding natural
health care. Last month we opened up a kind of discussion on the alternative approaches
to cancer with an emphasis on the metabolic defects which you have fairly set principles
that you have uncovered over time, some of which obviously don't line up with kind of regular
medicine. I know you have a very alternative perspective towards treating people and I think
I'm right in saying that the first do no harm rationale will be something you hold quite
closely. Modern cancer therapy and chemotherapy and radiotherapy, I don't think these are modalities
of which you are at all in favor of but that's a very personal choice that each patient who's
going through cancer therapy has to come up against but obviously going through
herbal medicine and alternative medicines, most people perhaps looking for alternatives are not
looking at conventional treatment anyway. Last month we covered cellular mitochondrial activity
and how that produces energy. We discussed the myth of sugar being cancer-promoting
which is fairly rife in the mainstream. It seems to be repeated almost daily that sugar is
something to be avoided for almost everything and you've dispelled that myth for sure.
Then the kind of neuroendocrine dysregulation, you mentioned things like estrogen driving not
only breast but other cancers and then the what they call the kind of hypothalamic pituitary
access where stress produces cortisol and through chronic stress the immune system can suffer and
how this is all part and parcel of a kind of weakened organism that does that in some ways
predispose to the lack of surveillance. So the last thing I think we got to was looking at redox
balancing and mentioning that the flavonoids are a fairly diverse group of plant products
in many, many different areas can be used to quench free radical damage which is part and
parcel also of cancer in its own right. I had some abstracts and that got my interest. I know you're
a big proponent of saturated fats and you do not at all adhere to polyunsaturated being in any way
healthy or beneficial for the organism and actually very much destruction and inflammation is caused
by them. So the abstracts I was looking at were things like lipid peroxidation which we have
talked about on many different shows at many different times and this peroxidation and
byproducts of lipid metabolism or lipid oxidation is what happens. These have been things that have
been shown to promote cancer. So the whole rationale of people using these omega 3s and
6s and fish oils as being "healthy" is absolutely not what you want to be using
if you've got a cancer diagnosis or even if you don't have a cancer diagnosis. How about that?
Yeah a couple of the abstracts you're referring to I think mentioned that on a high fish oil diet
the metastasis was about a thousand times worse than on a low fat diet or even a fat
efficient diet. Just a huge difference from supplementing fish oil versus not having fat.
And we can make all of the unsaturated and saturated fats that we need from carbohydrates.
So we don't really need any fats in the diet except for the pleasant taste
and helping to absorb other nutrients. These abstracts in particular showed the tremendous
prone metastatic effect of the fish oil fats. I saw the other references particularly for
liver metastasis and cancer growth in the liver. Obviously the liver is one of the major organs
blood flows through and so vascular-borne cancers that travel to different sites through the
vasculature can certainly become picked up in the liver and the liver itself because it's
kind of sinusoidal organ like a sponge if you like a matrix of very many capillaries and
openings and ducts and places where cancers can settle and grow are quite often seen in
cancer as a secondary spread to the liver. The other articles here that I saw said that these
omega-3s in particular I think the sixes were probably also implicated but the omega-3s
promoted along cancer metastasis to the liver and again there was a direct causal relationship
between these omega-3s and liver metastases. But Dr. Peat? Yes. Can you hear me okay? Yes.
So this lipid peroxidation or rancid fat that or when we eat fat it can go rancid if it's not
saturated and that's known as lipid peroxidation that applies to not only the fish oils but also
like all the vegetable seed oils right like the canola and the soy and all the vegetable oils.
The more highly unsaturated they are the quicker they break down and some of the oxidative breakdown
is almost immediately just as soon as it gets absorbed from your intestine and shows up in
your bloodstream you can find the highly oxidized breakdown fragments of the
polyunsaturated fats like fish oil. Did I hear you correctly stating that metastasis is a thousand
times worse in a fatty diet versus a non-fat diet? A couple of these studies found that
the number and quantity of identifiable metastatic cancer was in these cases a thousand times higher
and this would again lead to people that have talked about ketogenic diets. This is absolutely
the last thing you want to be doing right? Yeah and in the process of getting the ketogenic effect
but basically it's starvation and stress that turns on the so-called ketone production but
actually the so-called ketone bodies one of the major ketone bodies is actually not a ketone but
an alcohol hydroxyl group as a potential ketone but in the hydroxyl state which is formed during
the ketogenic diet this becomes a reductant having an effect similar to lactic acid which is
a trigger to shift oxidation towards the fermentation or the lactic acid metabolism
typical of cancer and once anything interferes with your ability to oxidize glucose fully
that liberates any stored fatty acids you have in your tissues and everyone has an abundance of fat
mixed right into their functioning tissues and in the ketogenic state you are releasing free fatty
acids into the bloodstream and all of the liberated free fatty acids that have been studied promote
metastasis it isn't just the extremely toxic fish oil type but just the the fact of being a fatty
acid rather than a sugar there's many years ago someone named Randall noticed that when you're
if you increase the fat in your diet and it turns into free fatty acids the free fatty acids
block the particular enzyme of pyruvate dehydrogenase which lets us oxidize glucose
all the way to carbon dioxide and the free fatty acids directly activate the
enzyme that knocks out our ability to oxidize glucose and so once you get ketogenic
from some degree of starvation then you're poisoning your ability to fully oxidize glucose
that leaves it producing lactic acid and when the pyruvate dehydrogenase is poisoned by various
things but especially free fatty acids then you shift over to the cancer metabolism producing
lactic acid which shifts the metabolism of other cells in the same direction. So would that apply
to saturated fat but at a lesser extent? Yeah in some cases certain saturated fats
don't do that at all but on average whenever it's been studied the Randall effect works as soon as
our glucose oxidation is interfered with by rising free fatty acids.
Right so this isn't really alternative medicine because this is scientifically backed
and researched information that Dr. Peat's sharing with us tonight that
might not be applied in orthodox medical treatment of cancer but this is in no way
on the fringe of science this is this is scientific information. Yeah it actually
represents 60 more more than 60 years of investigating what is actually happening
in the metabolism of stress and cancer and the whole thing that has developed in the last
50 years of saying that cancer eats sugar cancer lives on sugar therefore if you stop eating sugar
you'll start with a cancer that's absolutely 100% wrong. What sugar starvation does
is cause the Randall cycle to take effect blocking your ability to oxidize sugar
fully so you oxidize your fermented producing lactic acid which promotes more of the cancer
metabolism and creates inflammation and brings up the cortisol stress hormones that break down
proteins to make more of the glucose or amino acids which will feed the cancer
the fatty acids themselves are good food for the cancer but at a certain point of wasting away
from cancer fatty acids aren't very abundant in the body and so the lactic acid metabolism is
maintained by turning body proteins into glucose and amino acids to support the lactic acid
metabolism of cancer. So in general when you consult with people that might have cancer
would you recommend them to eat then a non-fat or very low-fat diet and a very high sucrose
and fructose diet? Yeah carbohydrates in general especially sucrose.
Which is sugar folks and honey and sugar chemically identical. Yeah I think it was last
month I mentioned the grape diet it was famous in the 40s and 50s. It was a very high glucose
and sucrose diet combined with a very high intake of the anti-inflammatory flavonoids
but those are two of the very important anti-cancer agents the anti-inflammatory
component of the diet that you get in fruits and vegetables and then the abundance of the minerals
and other nutrients of fruit but an abundance of sucrose so that you don't recur don't resort to
any tendency to liberate fatty acids.
Okay you're listening to ask your doctor KMUD 91.1 FM from 730 to the end of the show. Callers are
welcome to call in with questions related to this month's continuing topic of cancer and cancer
alternatives. Again a number if you're outside or even in the area 707 923 3911 our guest speaker
Dr Raymond Peat. Dr Peat I wanted to I wanted to question you about something that
from a herbal medicine perspective is very important for you know basically as an anti-cancer
strategy as well as recognizing the the actual function and value of the lymphatics in I know
in breast cancer and lymph nodes obviously become congested they pick up cancer cells,
they are true they are primarily white cell surveillance sites with other cells that are
killer cells etc they're doing some kind of routine surveillance of all of the fluids that
are constantly passing through them but I wanted to get to the point of a few years ago now it
hasn't been discovered long I think I read in a science magazine maybe two or three years ago
a new organ that science had finally uncovered and it was because of a laser type treatment
of endoscopy that previously when they had fixed tissue to look at microscopically
they saw that these collagen sheaths and bundles look fairly flattened and fairly solid in these
tissues but yet when they use these lasers they saw that these were structural cavities that were
filled with fluid and they called this this material this ground substance and the interstitium
and they now say that this interstitium is a fit organ and primarily I think one of the largest
organ in the body but it's responsible obviously for the metastases of cancer cells
and in herbal medicine like I said the the principle word that I think of
is pogru has been traditionally used for breast cancer as well as other cancers certainly has
lymphatic immunostimulant anti-inflammatory activity and like I said it's definitely been
used it's certainly in Europe ongoing and it's been in the herbal pharmacopoeia for many years
in the treatment of cancers and specifically for lymphatic cancers and breast cancers but
what do you what do you understand about the interstitium and this so-called ground
substance through which I think some of these compounds I think one namely now the main compound
from phytolacca is having its activity with but obviously other agents get into the lymphatics
that is obviously a pathway for many different substances the following structures have been
identified within this previously thought to be amorphous extravascular system a Korean
named Bongan Kim I think it was in the 1960s called it the third circulatory system
and what are now known as the exosomes a large number of these small vesicles secreted by cells
are transported outside the blood vessels some of them in inside the ordinary
blood stream but many of them flow through apparent channels in the extracellular material
that seem to be almost specific for carrying the lipid the micro vesicles or exosomes
from a cell under stress to to a cell which is for example in the bone marrow that can
produce repair factors and send it back through the the various circulatory systems lymphatic
or the extra lymphatic when identified by the Korean or via the bloodstream itself
to either correct a tumor or in some cases make it worse depending on the state of the organism
and we have a couple of callers okay we're good let's um let's hold that hold that there kind of
just got into the subject of connective tissue health as it shows uh can I take the direction
of this next subject but let's take this first caller uh caller you're on the air where are you
from what's your question uh it was a local person who's was a very bad connection but I was able to
they very simple they wanted to know uh what you thought of flax oil and what you thought of avocados
uh avocados are good enough very pleasant nutritious food but uh you don't want to
eat very large quantities as a regular quantity just because there is some unsaturated
polyunsaturated fat in it and the the flax oil is also a very highly polyunsaturated
so it the flax meal has a laxative effect a bulk laxative action
so the flax meal can be a protective anti-cancer but you don't want to
build up a reserve of the polyunsaturated fats found in flax oil and here's your next caller
okay and uh his friend uh I just wanted to say I have two miraculous stories I'll start with my
my own uh quickly uh I uh developed a a chest cancer and uh I knew it was cancer because it's
uh a cancer of that type it really feels like a little needle inside of your chest and I knew
exactly what to do I don't can't tell you why I knew what to do but I had had ordered from a
essential oil company uh a product called frankincense and I opened up the clear glass bottle
and I liberal liberally put it on my chest and in four hours later the pain stopped
and I I know I had killed the cancer I just absolutely bathed it in the frankincense
it didn't return ever it's been 10 years now that was my story uh and no one knew about it except
me and I was quite proud of that uh the other was my sister went down to San Francisco to
UCSF and she was uh the the doctors said you have a cancer and she was very upset about that of
course and we would all be as I was as well and uh so I said look I I had used frankincense prior
to this time to kill kill cancer uh start that program so I went down and I got her some um
several three or four ounces of frankincense now this was older frankincense it was about
maybe six months to a year old out that I call it out of date and uh I gave that to her and she
started doing that and now we're just basic people you know she has a college degree I have
two years of college and uh so I'm talking hopefully on just a level I'm not a doctor
myself I don't claim to be a physician I'm just telling you what I have done to be successful and
uh so I started her on that program of applying it into the area and I've also used it internally
before and as long as you don't use too much and we're all different I was also taking an
internally for a while mixing it with with like a some sort of water or juice and that seems to
have cleansed out my system as well uh she started on the program of using the frankincense topically
and she said I had a cyst on the front of the front of my body and started using it and she
said about three months later that little cyst fell out onto her finger and she was quite
astonished about that but the other thing that she didn't tell me about that what she was using was
something called zeolite and uh z-e-o-l-i-t-e I believe and uh she said that it was taking the
heavy metals out of the body and excreting them out she has been a person that's eaten organically
her whole life she is intolerant cannot take calcium through dairy products and she has her
own way she's a vegetarian she has her own gardens and she's lived this way her whole life what do
you think of those two things right okay well I'll mention frankincense and her name is Boswellia
sacra and I was going to mention it one of many herbs that had been used for cancer specifically
I think the skin cancers um so Boswellia is one that we were going to mention uh and then the
zeolite sounds like a chelating agent um Dr. Peat do you know much about zeolite and issues
I didn't hear all of that but uh frankincense and myrrh contain a variety of
tight terpenes that are struck similarly to the steroids and they haven't actually been
studied enough to define exactly how their anti-cancer effect works
okay you're listening to Ask Herb Doctor KMUD Garverville 91.1 FM from now until the end of
the show eight o'clock you're invited to call in the questions that are related to cancer
uh the number is 707-923-3911 and we're still in our little uh fundraising thing could you maybe
put out a plea to your listeners because I know there's people who tune in from literally all
over the world for the show it's kind of a unique radio station that we have this platform for Dr.
Peat here and for you guys and it's pledge drive time okay yeah well uh for those people that are
listening to the show I just want you to recognize that we still have a free speech radio program I
think that's the most important thing that people need to remember I've said this before that free
speech is very important it's one of our main principle constitutional rights to hear both sides
of the discussion I think when things become one-sided that's when we become seriously
uh in trouble and so this radio station has many different people speaking on many different
platforms and what I really appreciate is that they give time for both sides they give time to
all sides they're not exclusive so as one of those few places I think that is still left they have a
pretty balanced viewpoint from people from different camps and so it's got to be something
that you guys value here especially people living equally I think up in the hills etc some of these
people they listen to this show a lot it's one of their main sources of information they get news
articles from around the world it's not just local politics but national and international
and so if you want to keep the radio station going folks I strongly encourage you to send
money in and donations however much you can afford it does need to be funded it does get
some funding externally but it's definitely has a shortfall in its budget annually but every year
people donate and they step up to the plate and thank goodness KMUD is still on the airwaves I
appreciate it very much to give us a platform here to give people alternatives and for those
people that are listening now please if you haven't already joined as a member please consider
calling in giving a donation either one time or a revolving donation it all goes to help keep this
local radio station going and out of the hands of sole proprietors with single genders so please go
ahead and make that call yeah I'm not even so sure that we're trying to have every side of every idea
you know put out across the air it's more that as a community we have so many different community
members who do have a little time on air that all together in the aggregate we get an awful lot of
opinions and if you don't hear an opinion on here that you want to hear on here then that's when you
call in and thank jobs Friday or some other show when it's appropriate and express your opinion or
all sides now okay so once again the number 707 923 3911 so Dr. Peat just getting back to
the herbal medicine perspective of improving the connective tissue and strengthening the
connective tissue and the interstitium being a pathway a highway through which fluids move
and can either be picked up in the lymphatic if they are things like bacterial or yeast or
fungal spores etc and trapped and dealt with and neutralized the cancer is also able to use this
same highway to be taken to distant sites but there's definitely is a rationale for
improving the connective tissue itself as cancer tissue cancer cells and cancers
locally break down adjacent tissues and invade them in their quest for access to the vascular
shear or the lymphatics what do you think about agents that we're familiar with things like
horsetail a rich source of silica or whether it's phyto lacquer and the main components of phyto
lacquer that have this lymphatic immune stimulating activity and do you think there's a value in what
do you see as a value in improving and toning these tissues I know you mentioned a lot about
calcium and calcium obviously is part and parcel of improving the extracellular matrix and its
homeostasis between being stored in the bone and being available in the bloodstream is something
you see people get plenty of calcium for and the role of calcium is very closely related to
energy metabolism and inflammation when you're deficient in energy you activate many of the
pro-inflammatory peptides and small lipid molecules that in an ideal situation that
momentary increase of inflammation can reactivate the design and repair processes
especially for the connective tissue but getting the energy and essential nutrients provided
is going to have an anti-inflammatory effect which allows the energy production to take effect
and maintain structural integrity and the effect of adequate calcium in your diet
is to oppose the excitatory effects of too much phosphate in your diet so the calcium
is having an anti-inflammatory pro-energy restoration effect and that has the
effect of maintaining structural integrity of the interstitial the whole structural framework
holds cells together. We've got a caller. Not only anti-cancer but you're mentioning
the benefits it has on maintaining healthy connective tissue as well.
You know keeping inflammation down and energy up.
Okay so Michael did you say that there was another caller? Yes there is a caller.
Yeah go ahead let's take this next caller away from what's your question?
Hi I'm from Garberville and I had a low-grade bladder cancer and it came back again and they
just take it out but I was wondering if you had any recommendations and I think I'll take my
answer on the air. Okay so Dr. Peat low-grade bladder cancer what would you suggest as being
good approaches about obviously everything that we had previously talked about but
go ahead and speak to that. There have been several people developed effective treatments
by infusing a mixture of nutrients, vitamin A related things, proteolytic enzymes and stabilizing
anti-inflammatory things such as I think lidocaine was one of them into the bladder and then arranging
the person's posture so that the mixture is in contact with the actual tumor itself so you can
get a very high concentration on the tumor and several of those procedures have been very
effective at removing persistent bladder tumors. Okay so let me just repeat that to make sure that
we heard you correctly. So you said there's been research done to show that an infusion
of proteolytic enzymes, vitamin A compounds and lidocaine infused with the person laying down in
such a way that the you know whether it was on the back of the bladder wall or the front of the
bladder wall laying on their back or their front is that what you mean? Yeah I'm not sure if that
was a complete list of the ingredients but two or three groups were using very similar groups
with a very high tumor rate. And what is infusion in this context? For treating tumors on the wall
of the bladder. Are you putting that up through the urethra or are you drinking that? Oh yeah
filling the bladder with a mixture of filling it. All right and you also said anti-inflammatory
things so maybe like aspirin maybe. Would they have refused aspirin into the bladder? I didn't
hear that. Would they have used something like aspirin as well as an anti-inflammatory? I always
recommend aspirin for any cancer. It reduces inflammation, helps to restore the energy level
and has at least a dozen effects that help to control or eliminate cancer.
Very good. Okay you're listening to Ask your doctor KMUD. Garverville 91.1 FM from now until
the close of the show 8 o'clock. You're invited to call in the questions. The number is 707 923 3911
Dr. Raymond P. Willis in the studio. And I just want to say I always like to
put the warning out there that if people are choosing to use aspirin
for treating their own cancers and they're doing a home treatment like that
you should really call us and we'll give you the instructions on how to take aspirin safely
in conjunction with vitamin K2. It's very important if you're taking more than a baby
aspirin a day that you take vitamin K2 to prevent blood subleaving. And also you don't really have
till 8 o'clock you should call right away because we got to give them time to finish up and if you
do call in right away you got to keep it brief. No what I mean sorry let's um if anyone wants to
use aspirin any more than a baby aspirin a day then email us or call us at our number which is
western botanical medicine 707 986 9506 and our email is either Andrew or Sarah at western
botanicalmedicine.com and Sarah is within h s-a-r-a-h at western botanicalmedicine.com
Okay so Dr. Peat how about I mean again aspirin I think just as we mentioned it talking about
the coagulopathy that happens with cancer and even if it's not stimulated by estrogen which
promotes blood thickening and clotting and is pro-cancer in its own right. The approach to treatment
as anti-coagulopathy treatment in terms of making the the platelets less sticky making blood flow
more easily um do you do you think this would be uh would have a good rational basis in science
for using things like aspirin and garlic and things like inco and other things that got
traditionally used for improving blood flow and preventing clotting. The clotting system
and the platelets are very central to the ability of of the metastatic cells
to get across the blood vessel into the area it's going to colonize as metastatic cancer
and various things that decrease the stickiness and the tendency to coagulate of the platelets
several of these substances have been studied and very strongly discourage metastatic spread
and so increase the survival rate lidocaine aspirin and progesterone are just three of the
factors that have been over and over demonstrated to interfere with the metastatic
stickiness and the ability to travel in the cancer cells makes them stay home and not hurt anything.
Stay home cancer stay home. How about I have on my next question kind of anti-angiogenic
activity to manage cancer a little bit like diabetes because diabetes has been implicated
in the breakdown of vascular walls. There were studies in the 40s and 50s showing that
the longer people left their cancer untreated the longer they lived and several studies have
looked at the statistics and the population in general showing that the more you treat
in some cancers that the survival rate stays the same no matter how much you
do to the patient but in some cases the more you treat the higher the death rate is
that that was first seen distinctly in the case of prostate cancer in the early 90s
and by the end of the century this had been pressed enough prostate specialists that they
came up with the idea of a watchful waiting figuring that if you don't
use any of the harmful treatments such as high dose estrogen to treat the prostate cancer and just
watch what's happening don't do multiple biopsies and so on but the normal aging process
happens faster than the development of a normal old man's prostate cancer
and that's a well-established concept now that watchful waiting has actually improved
the mortality rate from cancer failing to treat it. Well what's that statistic you quote Dr. Peat
that 99 percent or 99.9 percent of people over the age of 50 have some form of abdominal cancer
99.9 percent of people will not die of cancer? In an autopsy you can find
cancer essentially in a hundred percent of the people over 50 if you look for it it's part of
a natural healing process and most people just coexist with many of these little cancers that
aren't really hurting anything. I think on a very quick side note just for people to help people
if they want to try this themselves and advocate self-treatment generally but on a very small side
note I had a keratosis and what I thought was a keratosis on the side of my nose and I've spoken
to you about this so to speak three or four years ago I had it for two years it obviously wasn't
healthy cells in your latest photograph your nose looks fine and no defect at all. I just wanted to
tell people that I had it you know fortunately or unfortunately I did have a biopsy done and it
identified it as basal cell carcinoma and of course they wanted to do this and everything
with it which I refused. I went ahead and did what you suggested I do I don't have it anymore
I mean folks it's possible your nose looks very positive. Anyway before we end I want to mention
a book that I think might be the most important book published in the last two or three years
just came out. It's Robert Kennedy Jr's The Real Anthony Fauci. It was the background for the
not only the COVID process but the background going back decades.
Yeah well he's been there as indeed for 40 years or something he's pretty entrenched.
Dr. Fauci is pretty entrenched.
Yeah but this book I think is going to change that.
Yeah they said possibly he's prejudiced himself but anyway thanks so much for your time Dr. Peat
it's five to the hour I know the engineer wants to wrap it up for eight o'clock and we need to
give people your information so thanks so much for joining us. Okay thank you. And thank you Dr. Peat
good night. Next. So those people who've listened to the show before or who just tuned in Dr. Raymond
Peat's got a wealth of experience he's been doing this over 40 years he's written several books
he's published hundreds of hundreds of articles. He's a very altruistic character as most people
who've known him can attest. His website is raypeat.com and so his journal articles there
are well referenced. He's a very scientific person he doesn't believe in hocus pocus and crystal
dangling and whatever else I'm sorry to offend some people who maybe use crystals I'm not saying
that they don't work or do anything but it's generally a a do less than do something proactive
situation. So we can be contacted Monday through Friday work within botanicalmedicine.com
the 707 986 9506. And so until the December version we will look forward to seeing you,
hearing from you, answering questions, give us feedback and thanks so much for your time.
Thank you. Happy Thanksgiving and thanks for tuning in. My name is Sarah Murray.
My name is Andrew Murray. Good night.
[Music]